Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Der VfL Wolfsburg ist Frauen-Bundesliga-Meister. Das überrascht so wirklich keinen mehr. Deshalb wollen wir heute mal über was anderes sprechen. Wir sprechen mit Sascha Reiß, sportlichem Leiter vom SC Sand. Ich begrüße euch sehr herzlich, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, hier zu Rasenfunk-Kurzpass Nr. 203. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter und wir wollen heute auf die Frauenbundesliga schauen, aber mal in einer etwas anderen Perspektive. Wir sprechen hier immer viel über das Meisterschaftsrennen. Das ist jetzt entschieden. Wir sprechen hier viel über die Champions League. Da gibt es noch ein bisschen was, was sich am letzten Spieltag erklären lässt. Worüber wir aber seltener sprechen, ist die Perspektive der Vereine gegen Ende der Tabelle. Und da haben wir in dieser Woche etwas Besonderes für euch. Ich freue mich sehr, dass wir mit Sascha Reiß sprechen konnten, mit dem sportlichen Leiter vom SC Sand. Dieses Gespräch könnt ihr jetzt gleich im Anschluss hören. Und ich wünsche euch damit viel Spaß. Ich begrüße jetzt bei mir Sascha Reiß, sportlicher Leiter vom SC Sand. Hallo Herr Reiß. Ja, ich freue mich, dass Sie hier sind. Jetzt haben wir auch ein spannendes Wochenende hinter uns gehabt. Das gab ein 1 zu 0 im Heimspiel gegen den ersten FC Köln. Was waren denn Ihre Erkenntnisse aus diesem Spiel? Was kann man daraus mitnehmen jetzt für den letzten Spieltag noch?
Ja, wir sind am Leben, so kann man es vielleicht sagen. Also wir haben natürlich die Woche davor beim Auswärtsspiel in Freiburg mit der deutlichen Niederlage. Ja, da lagen wir schon sehr am Boden und haben uns jetzt einfach für das Heimspiel vorgenommen gehabt, dass wir uns ordentlich präsentieren, nochmal vor Heimpublikum einfach ein gutes Spiel machen und dann einfach auch abwarten, was was macht Essen eventuell im Parallelspiel gegen Freiburg. Kriegen wir es hin und gewinnen das Spiel und haben noch eine kleine Möglichkeit. Und ja, das ist uns dann im Grunde auch zum Glück gelungen. Die Mannschaft hat gestern ein wirklich gutes Spiel gemacht, was die Intensität anging. War es von beiden Mannschaften auch ein gutes Spiel? Auch Köln hat sich da gut präsentiert. Ich glaube, jedes knappe Ergebnis wäre irgendwo gerechtfertigt gewesen. Wir hatten gestern so ein bisschen das Quäntchen Glück und vor allem haben wir dann auch zu Null gespielt, um das Spiel dann auch nach Hause zu bringen. Und so haben wir jetzt einfach noch die Chance, am letzten Spieltag in Hoffenheim selbst mit einem Sieg, ja, was dafür zu tun und müssen natürlich gucken, dass uns, ja, vielleicht Jena sogar Schüttenhilfe leistet und wir das Unmögliche möglich machen und doch noch in der Liga bleiben.
Also, Jena tritt in Essen an und Sie haben es ja gerade schon gesagt, in Hoffenheim, da geht es dann eben um den letzten Abstiegsplatz, zwei Punkte Rückstand sind es gerade auf Essen. Würden Sie denn sagen, mit Blick jetzt auf diese Partie gegen den ersten FC Köln, dass dieses enge Ergebnis auch dafür spricht, dass generell in der Liga der Schluss der Tabelle näher herangerückt ist an das Mittelfeld?
Im Vergleich zur letzten Saison muss ich sagen, dass das Ende ein bisschen näher zusammengerückt ist, ein bisschen ausgeglichener geworden. Bremen hat viele gute, viele knappe Spiele auch gespielt, wir selbst auch. Wir haben deutlich besseres Torverhältnis als letztes Jahr und stehen aber weiter unten und haben deutlich weniger Punkte. Also wie gesagt, die Ergebnisse sind knapper geworden. Es gibt zwar immer noch diese Ausreißer, jetzt am Wochenende war das ja auch der Fall mit Wolfsburg gegen Jena, aber in Summe sind die Spiele enger, qualitativ besser. Die Intensität, die Mannschaften sind enger zusammengerückt und das macht die Liga dann auch wieder ein bisschen attraktiver an sich.
Und gleichzeitig werden damit die einzelnen Partien noch mal wichtiger. Da gab es zwei ganz wichtige Heimspiele für Sie gegen Essen und gegen Werder. Das eine 1 zu 1, das andere wurde 0 zu 1 verloren. Das war dieser 1 zu 0-Siege, die Werder eingefahren hat, wirklich bemerkenswert, was man mit neun erzielten Toren machen kann in 21 Spielen. Wenn wir jetzt mal so ein vorweggenommenes Fazit ziehen und damit mal uns von der Frage lösen, ob es jetzt runtergeht in Liga 2 oder ob der Klassenerhalt noch klappt. Sie haben ja einen Trainerwechsel vorgenommen. Matthias Friböse wurde ersetzt durch Alexander Fischinger, der jetzt dann schon zum dritten Mal beim SCS angetreten ist. Wie würden Sie jetzt im Nachhinein diese Entscheidung bewerten? War das richtig?
Gut, wir waren im Sommer ja auch erstmal gezwungen, den Alexander zu ersetzen. Er hat ja letztes Jahr schon das Wunder geschafft und aus den letzten vier Spielen uns den Klassenerhalt gebracht mit zehn Punkten. Das war ja schon ein Hussareinstück. Wir wollten mit ihm natürlich unbedingt weitermachen und wir haben da im Sommer auch beide Seiten drum gekämpft, aber er hat es einfach aus der beruflichen Perspektive nicht hinbekommen. Er hat nebenher eine Fußballschule und da musste er einfach noch gewisse Dinge regeln. War auch noch bei seinem Heimatverein im Herrenfußball im Wort und hat das noch gestemmt. Der Einstieg bei uns, der kurzfristige da im Frühjahr letzten Jahres, war ja im Grunde auch nur Corona-bedingt möglich. Und dann haben wir mit Matthias eigentlich einen Neustart gehabt im Sommer, der zwar auf eine Mannschaft zurückgreifen konnte, die dann quasi eingespielt war. Wir hatten nicht viele Abgänge im Vergleich zu sonstigen Jahren davor. Allerdings war unser Saisonstart einfach auch sehr, sehr schwierig. Wir haben auswärts in Frankfurt dann knapp 2-1 verloren, dann Bayern und Wolfsburg hintereinander weg. Die Ergebnisse waren zwar knapp, aber wurden halt alle drei Spiele verloren. Dann war es für ihn einfach schwierig, dann kam ein Heimspiel gegen Jena, da ging es dann los mit unserer Verletzten-Misere. Gerade die zwei Offensivspielerinnen, Chiara Loos und Summer Green, die für uns quasi elementar sind, sind dann in der Vorrunde ausgefallen oder immer mal wieder mit muskulären Problemen. Und ja, so hat sich das so ein bisschen durchgezogen in der Vorrunde. Wir haben leider nur zwei Punkte geholt. Gerade diese zwei Spiele Bremen im Pokal gewinnen wir dort 1-0. Eine Woche später dieses unglückliche 0-1 mit in meinen Augen immer noch sehr zweifelhaften Elfmeter. Hat uns dann einfach Punkte gekostet und wir hatten dann zwei Punkte, als wir dann als Verein gesagt haben, wir müssen was tun, wir müssen reagieren, auch schon frühzeitiger. Das war dann im November und konnten dann auch wieder auf den Alexander Fischinger zurückgreifen, wo wir dann wussten, okay, der kennt die Mannschaft, die Mannschaft steht voll dahinter, wir können quasi da anfangen, wo wir vielleicht auch in der Schlussphase der Vorsaison aufgehört hatten. Aber auch da war dann einfach der Wechsel, der musste erst mal fruchten, hat dann gedauert, bis kurz vor der Winterpause. Und eigentlich ging es dann erst ab der Rückrunde so richtig los. Also wir haben jetzt zehn Punkte geholt, wenn man die Rückrunde betrachtet. Und nimmt man mal die zwei Spiele Bremen und Essen, die sie gerade ansprechen, raus. Das waren nämlich zwei Heimspiele, da haben wir mit deutlich mehr gerechnet. Und gerade in diesen zwei Spielen haben wir einfach keine guten Leistungen auf dem Platz bekommen. Warum? Das fragen wir uns manchmal selbst noch, weil es gerade ebenso entscheidend war. Aber so ist das, wenn sie uns natürlich dann trifft am Ende, dann muss man es vielleicht schon da festmachen, dass wir in der Vorrunde diese Verletzungsprobleme hatten, das nicht kompensieren konnten, dass die wichtigen Spiele auch nicht gewonnen oder die direkten Duellen quasi verloren gingen. Und in der Rückrunde hatten wir zwar noch die Chance, aber die zwei Heimspiele, manchmal muss man halt auf dem Punkt da sein. Das waren wir nicht jeweils.
Heimspiele haben immer schon eine große Rolle gespielt für den SC Sand. Liegt das daran, weil der SCS so ein bisschen mit jeder fortschreitenden Saison mehr aus der Zeit fällt, weil eben mehr Profi-Vereine von unten nachrücken mit anderen infrastrukturellen Möglichkeiten?
Ich finde einfach, wir haben einen Vorteil, wenn man die Zuschauer sieht. Bei uns natürlich sind alle ein bisschen näher dran. Wir spielen jetzt nicht in einem riesen Stadion, wo sich dann eventuell 500 oder 1000 Leute auch verlaufen können, wo man die Nähe nicht spürt, den Fan nicht spürt, die Unterstützung vielleicht gar nicht so mitbekommt. Das ist natürlich eine andere Situation. Bei uns waren gestern in Anführungszeichen nur 700 Zuschauer, aber die Zuschauer und die Fans haben die Mannschaft dann gerade in der zweiten Halbzeit auch ein Stück weit mitgetragen. Ich sage jetzt mal klar, Corona hat uns da ja auch einen Strich durch die Rechnung gemacht und gerade in der Vorsaison war es ja nicht möglich und jetzt aktuell waren ja dann teilweise auch Beschränkungen oder ist es vielleicht auch der Fan teilweise gar nicht mehr so richtig gewohnt, sich auszulassen und im Stadion da richtig Stimmung zu machen. Aber wir haben da einfach einen guten Zuschauerschnitt und eine gute Unterstützung und einen tollen Fanclub, der mit uns da Woche für Woche arbeitet und auch auch auswärts uns unterstützt.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen das Paradoxe, wenn man auf den aktuellen Zustand in der Frauenbundesliga guckt, dass man da Vereine unterschiedlichster Couleur hat, eben solche, die im Profi-Männerbereich unterwegs sind und auch im Frauenfußball und dann eben solche wie den SCS, die ja auch vom DFB gesondert aufgeschlüsselt werden, immer wenn es zum Beispiel um Finanzen geht. Und wenn ich jetzt nach der Zuschauertabelle gehe, die letzten veröffentlichten Zahlen sind noch aus der Saison 1920, das ist wegen Corona auch alles ein bisschen, da hinken wir ein bisschen hinterher mit den Zahlen, da liegt der Sand auf Rang 6 der Tabelle, das heißt es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Vereinen und damals waren das unter anderem auch noch Hoffenheim, Bayern, Köln und Leverkusen, die hinter Sand liegen. Wie bewerten Sie das denn jetzt, wenn so eine Mannschaft wie der SCS eventuell aus der Liga verschwindet? Was geht denn damit, den Frauenfußball in Deutschland verloren?
Ja, ich finde einfach, der SC Sand hat ja schon dieses Alleinstellungsmerkmal, ein reiner Frauenfußballverein zu sein. Wir haben zwar eine Herrenmannschaft, die spielt aber in der untensten Liga und das sind Freunde quasi aus dem Dorf, die sich da zusammentun. Da gibt es auch keine Gelder oder irgendwas vom Verein, sondern bei uns wird alles für den Frauenfußball getan, von oben bis runter zu den Mädchenmannschaften. Und dieses Flair auch bei uns, wo es dann wirklich darum geht, reiner Frauenfußball und nicht nur eine Abteilung zu sein, das lebt ja der Verein auch schon jetzt 42 Jahre. Wir sind seit acht Jahren in der Bundesliga. Der SC Sand ist, glaube ich, gerade im Frauenfußball schon ein Begriff und ein Unikat. Und ich glaube, es wird dann nicht nur erst beim SC Sand die ein oder andere Träne sein, sondern dem allgemeinen Frauenfußball-Fan, da sind wir schon wohl gesonnen. Andererseits muss man dann einfach auch diese Zeit und die Entwicklung sehen. Da es uns natürlich immer schwerer fällt, da mit und Schritt zu halten. Andererseits arbeiten bei uns so viele mit Herzblut an der Sache. Und wir versuchen ja auch, selbst uns weiterzuentwickeln. Und ich glaube, das haben wir sogar in den letzten zwei Jahren, gerade in Corona-Zeiten auch ganz gut hingekriegt, dass wir auch in dem Bereich weiter dabei sein wollen. Also wenn es runtergeht, arbeiten wir fest daran, auch nächstes Jahr dann eine Liga tiefer und so aufzustellen, dass wir eventuell auch einen direkten Wiederaufstieg zumindest angehen können, ob der gelingt. Da liegt dann ja auch immer wieder vieles, viele andere dazwischen.
Ja, können Sie mal kurz erklären, die beiden Szenarien auch gerne ein bisschen aus finanzieller Sicht heraus. Was würde denn ein Klassenerhalt bedeuten und was ein Abstieg?
Das ist eigentlich relativ einfach, das zu erklären. Es gibt in der Bundesliga oder in der ersten Liga Fernseh- und Sponsoren-Liga Sponsorengelder von rund 350.000 Euro, die sind in der 3. Liga nur 40.000 Euro, so grob. Da merkt man natürlich schon, was das für ein Unterschied ist. Vor allem, wenn ein Verein wie der SC Sand jetzt nicht irgendwie einen Lizenzverein im Rücken hat, wo man vielleicht auch sagt, okay, wir fangen das irgendwie intern auf, sondern das sind ja die Gelder, die wir dann auch benötigen. Ja, wie gesagt, wir haben die letzten 2, 2,5 Jahre viel daran gearbeitet, auch beim SC Sand das ganze Thema Frauenfußball zu professionalisieren mit fest angestellten Leuten in allen Bereichen, im Trainerteam, im Staff außen rum, selbst im Marketing, Pressestelle, etc. Auch Dinge, die natürlich auch vom DFB gefordert werden in dem Bereich. Ja, das ist eigentlich so der Punkt, wo man dann so ein bisschen zurückschrauben muss und wo man dann einfach schaut, dass man gewisse Gelder auch wieder einspart. Der Kader kann natürlich nicht in der Breite gehalten werden. Ja, ein Stück weit ist natürlich auch unseren Sponsoren dann zu verdanken, dass wir dann trotzdem noch einigermaßen stemmen können. Die halten uns größtenteils die Stange zum Glück, sodass wir einfach, wie gesagt, vielleicht nicht diese Komplettprofessionalität, die wir aktuell führen, beibehalten können, sondern wir müssen ein bisschen runterfahren, Vormittagseinheit weniger, dass halt auch Spielerinnen die Möglichkeit haben, einen kleinen Minijob wahrzunehmen, um halt einfach gewisse Gelder dann auch selbst zu verdienen, um weiter dann professionell Fußball spielen zu können. Und dann am Ende des Monats natürlich auch den Verpflichtungen beizukommen.
Und wird das diese Einsparung, weil das ist ja durchaus deutlich mit fast einem Zehntel der Einnahmen, die man in der zweiten Liga hat im Vergleich zur ersten Liga, kann das auch zur Entlassung führen bei Ihnen, wenn Sie sagen, man hat sich jetzt professionalisiert, ja auch durchaus aus Professionalisierungswünschen des Verbands gegenüber dem Verein heraus?
Ja einerseits müssen wir natürlich im Kader, wie ich gerade schon gesagt habe, oder können wir uns nur noch in kleineren Kader zulegen. Der wird natürlich dann auch, ja nicht die Obergehälter, wird es dann auch nicht mehr geben. Auch da müssen wir gewisse Dinge streichen. Habe ich ja gerade gesagt, dass Spielerinnen dann auch fast gezwungen werden, selber sich noch ein bisschen was dazu zu verdienen, wobei wir da auch einen guten Partner haben mit so einer Charity-Organisation, die Übungsleiterstunden bezahlt für Migrationskinder, wo wir als SC Sand stark dabei sind. Da leisten die Spielerinnen einfach Übungsleiterstunden. Das ist dann auch im Fußballbereich. Da geht dann nicht alles über den Verein. Ja, und ansonsten drum herum, klar das Trainerteam, das war sehr, sehr breit, mit Chef-Trainer, mit einem festangestellten Co-Trainer, mit noch einem weiteren Co-Trainer, Athletiktrainer, festangestellter Physios. Da müssen wir mit Sicherheit auch gucken, dass wir da einfach den Rotstift ein bisschen ansetzen, auf welchen Position das dann genau sein wird. Müssen wir schauen, auch wie das Wochenende ausgeht. Vielleicht trifft es uns ja auch nicht in der Form, aber wir schaffen da doch noch ein kleines Wunder. Dann müssen wir zum Glück nicht über solche Dinge reden, sondern dann unterhalten wir uns ab nächster Woche, wie wir den Kader verbessern können. Aber wenn es eben so kommt, müssen wir natürlich den Schritt gehen, klar.
Welches sind denn die Argumente, mit denen Sie als sportlicher Leiterspielerin dazu bringen können, nach Sand zu kommen? Was sind die positiven Dinge, die Sie vielleicht auch im Vergleich zur Konkurrenz hervorheben, in solchen Gesprächen?
Das erste, was ich immer herausstelle, ist, dass es bei uns nicht anders ist, als in jedem anderen Bundesligaverein. Dass es alles gibt, dass es alles hat. Wir haben jetzt zwar keine fünf Trainingsplätze oder Rasentrainingsplätze, sondern eben nur zwei. Aber ich sage immer, eine Bundesligamannschaft kann auch immer nur auf einem Rasen trainieren. Wir haben zu Corona-Zeiten auch einen eigenen Athletikraum erstellt, zwar in einem Container, aber da hat es dann auch alles, was man für ein passendes Athletiktraining braucht und Krafttraining. Unser Staff ist entsprechend ausgestattet, wie ich gerade schon erklärt habe. Das ist schon mal so ein Hauptpunkt, weil mir begegnet es oft, dass viele einfach so ein bisschen die Befürchtung haben, beim SC Sand geht es ein bisschen amateurmäßig zu oder da fehlt an der ein oder anderen Geschichte. Viele kennen uns natürlich auch nur von den Spieltagen. Dann kommt man nach Sand gefahren auf ein Gelände, das nicht so üppig ist und kein großes Stadion, sondern wir sind ein Dorfverein und so ist auch das ganze Drumherum, was die Infrastruktur war das erste Mal. Ich sage das bewusst mit war, weil wir dann natürlich mobile Tribünen haben, eine Medien-Tribüne aufgebaut, einen Presseturm. Die Videoleinwand kam irgendwann mal danach. Jetzt werden im Sommer die Flutlichter gebaut für eine halbe Million, die dann tanzetauglich sind. Also es ist natürlich alles gewachsen oder am Entstehen immer noch. Aber im Endeffekt gibt es bei uns alles, was es braucht, was auch gefordert ist und was eigentlich auch ein Fußballerherz benötigt. Zusätzlich, was auch ein großer Vorteil ist, sind wir eben ein Verein, ein eigenständiger Verein. Ich habe gesagt, die alles für die Frauen macht, für den Frauenfußball. Wo ein ganzes Dorf dahinter steht, auch mit einer Sponsorenlandschaft, die wahnsinnig breit aufgestellt ist. Wir haben nicht nur diese zwei, drei großen Sponsoren oder sogar Konzernen, die halt einfach das Geld gibt, sondern bei uns ist das einfach fast schon ein Thema des Ortenaukreis an sich. Hier im Badischen, wo sich dann einfach ganz viele für den Frauenfußball auch bekennen, das Ganze unterstützen, dann aber auch zu den Spielen kommen und wir dann irgendwo dann auch nahbar sind. Ich habe auch mal gesagt, bei uns ist professionell der Leistungsgedanke. Wir üben mit Sicherheit auch nicht weniger Druck aus als woanders, aber bei uns geht es dann schon mal noch ein bisschen familiärer zu, auch nach einer Niederlage. Oder man nimmt auch mal eine Spielerin in den Arm, wenn es nicht so lief. Ich sage immer so schön, bei uns darf man auch ein Elfmeter verschießen und darf danach ins Clubhaus kommen, woanders ducken sie sich vielleicht ab und fahren nach Hause. Das ist dann nicht ganz so, manchmal ist es sogar genau der Spieler, der hat es dann am schönsten, wenn er es verschossen hat, weil dann wird einem am meisten gekümmert an dem Tag.
Sind vielleicht solche nicht sportlichen infrastrukturellen Umstände dann für den SCS noch wichtiger als für andere Vereine? Wenn ich mir angucke, regional gelegen hat man ja durchaus eine Konkurrenz im größeren Sinne zu Freiburg, zu Hoffenheim, wenn man so möchte auch noch bis hoch nach Frankfurt. Man liegt schön in seinem eigenen Eck ein bisschen, aber Sie haben es ja schon angesprochen, zum Beispiel die Nebenjobs, die Spielerinnen annehmen müssten, wenn es in die zweite Liga runterginge. Das sind ja für junge Frauen wahrscheinlich noch viel größere Argumente als manch andere. Was kann ich tun, um mir ein zweites Standbein aufzubauen, denn vom Fußball selbst zu leben, das ist immer noch sehr, sehr schwierig.
Und dass wir eben nicht diese Themen haben, mit nebenher sich noch einen Job suchen. Andererseits ist es natürlich möglich, wir haben auch drei, vier Spielerinnen, die das bewusst von sich aus machen, um vielleicht auch am freien Tag oder einfach noch einen weiteren Horizont zu haben, ein bisschen Ablenkung. Ja, das gibt es schon. Wenn wir natürlich in die zweite Liga gehen, sind wir auch so strukturiert. Das habe ich vorhin mit unserer Sponsorenlandschaft gemeint, dass wir da einfach viele Firmen im Boot haben, die vor allem auch im Mittelstand unterwegs sind, die uns dann einfach auch diese Möglichkeit geben, den Spielerinnen Teilzeitjobs, Minijobs anzubieten.
Wenn ich jetzt mal so gucke, wann höre ich über das Jahr hinweg, wenn ich nicht gerade mit Ihnen telefoniere vom SC Sand, dann ist das ehrlicherweise häufiger als ein Beispiel, dass andere Vereine, zum Beispiel, fällt mir der Bianca Rech ein, die war in einem Podcast von der Süddeutschen Zeitung zu Gast, und die hat den SC Sand verwendet als Beispiel dafür, was der Frauenfußball im Profibereich noch aufzuholen habe, was zum Beispiel Infrastruktur angeht. Sie haben die Flutlichtanlage jetzt schon angesprochen, Rasenheizung ist immer ein Thema generell, die Qualität des Rasens ist immer ein sehr großes Thema, vor allem wenn es mal nicht so läuft, wenn man auswärts ins Sand spielt. Fühlen Sie sich da manchmal auch ungerecht behandelt? Denn so eine Flutlichtanlage, Sie haben es ja schon angesprochen, 500.000 Euro kostet die. Jetzt haben wir ja gelernt, eine Saison in der Frauenbundesliga ermöglicht erst mal 350.000 an Einnahmen aus dem TV-Topf. Wie ist Ihre Perspektive auf solche Diskussionen?
Ja, ich fühle mich da absolut oder wir fühlen uns da eigentlich auch missverstanden an sich. Also gerade die Rasenthematik ist, glaube ich, seit zwei Jahren dürfte es keine mehr geben. Das Ganze rührt immer noch von Vorzeiten her, wo es vielleicht auch wirklich so war. Es gab auch mal ein Pokalspiel SC Sand gegen Bayern München, Halbfinale. Ich glaube, es war 2016, 2017. Da hat der SC Sand dann kurz vor Schluss ein entscheidender 2-1 geschlossen. Der Ball ist kurz vor dem Torwart nochmal aufgesprungen. Vielleicht auf einem englischen Wembleyrasen springt er nicht ganz so, aber dadurch ist der SC Sand weitergekommen. Ich glaube, die Bianca Rech hat es immer noch im Kopf. Das ist zwar fünf, sechs Jahre her, aber das schmerzt natürlich. Mittlerweile haben wir eine fest angestellte Greenkeeperin, die übrigens auch beim FC Bayern gelernt hat, die über den SC Sand und den Rasen dann auch ihre Masterarbeit geschrieben hat. Ich glaube, der Rasen erfüllt mittlerweile jeglichen Bundesliga-Standards. Wir haben natürlich jetzt nicht diesen Rollrasen, der wird ausgetauscht und liegt immer top tar. Aber ich glaube, man kann da mittlerweile sehr, sehr gut und sehr ordentlich. Ich glaube, in keinem Spiel dürfte jetzt mehr der Rasen schuld sein. Bei dem SC Sand, wenn man da gut oder schlecht spielt. Das gilt auch für uns. Wenn man das drumrum anspricht, finde ich es immer noch ein Stück weit. Ich kann die Argumentation und auch das, was die Außendarstellung angeht. Und wenn man das Ganze vermarkten möchte, dann kann ich das irgendwo nachvollziehen. In einem schönen Stadion oder in einem Campus oder so, da sehen die Fernsehbilder eventuell anders aus. Aber wenn diese Bilder ohne Zuschauer sind, und es ist leider immer noch so, die Stadion sind ja nicht gefüllt. Wir haben keine 10.000 Zuschauer oder 5.000 bei den Spielen, sondern wir kratzen dann am vierstelligen. Vielleicht mal sind 2.000 Zuschauer da. Und da ist unser Stadion ja eigentlich ein Musterbeispiel, dass bei diesen Zuschauerzahlen, dass es eigentlich in Sand da richtig Spaß macht, weil dann ist das Gelände... Also wir hatten 1.700 Zuschauer beim Heimspiel gegen Bayern München, und dann macht es auch richtig Spaß, weil die Fans eben nah dran sind und man auch als Spieler das spürt und die Stimmung auch im Stadion bleibt und sich nicht irgendwo verläuft, wie es dann eben woanders ist. Und dann macht es am TV-Bildschirm vielleicht auch immer ein einsames Bild, wenn man so ein verlorenes Fußballspiel sich anschauen muss. Also ich sag fast schon wie in Corona-Zeiten. Und von daher sehe ich uns eigentlich immer noch sehr gut aufgestellt. Also ich wünsche dem Frauenfußball auch, dass es kommt, wie es aktuell vielleicht auch in der Champions League läuft und in anderen Ländern, dass da richtige Zuschauerzahlen kommen. Oder jetzt in Wolfsburg natürlich mit 25.000, das ist natürlich sensationell. Ich wünsche mir, dass auch die Liga da einfach diesen Schwung mitnimmt und da entsprechende Zahlen kommen werden. Wenn wir dann noch dabei wären und bei uns im Sand ist dann eine Stadion-Auslastung von 3.000 Zuschauern, jedes Heimspiel, und man muss sich um die Karten schon fast anstehen, dann wäre das toll. Und wenn wir dann irgendwo Bestellungen hätten, nochmal 3.000 oder nochmal 5.000, alle wollen nach Sand, dann müsste man überlegen, auszubauen oder dann ein anderes Stadion zu suchen. Aber solange das nicht ist und generell nicht in der Liga ist, und auch andere Vereine das bei Weitem nicht haben, sehe ich diese Kritik ganz weit weg von uns. Da müssen andere Vereine, da muss ich mich vielleicht fragen als großer Verein, warum kriege ich es nicht hin, meine Fans an sich zu begeistern oder mache ich vielleicht auch da was in der Außenwirkung falsch, dass wir beim Herrenfußball dann die großen Massen und 70.000, aber bei den Frauen kriege ich gerade so vierstellig hin. Ich glaube da nicht, dass es nur am SC Sand liegt, sondern in der Außendarstellung werden ja andere Beispiele permanent gebracht. Wenn gerade die großen Vereine bessere Arbeit machen würden oder sich noch besser verkaufen würden, dann würden glaube ich alle profitieren.
Das war ja auch so ein bisschen die Haltung, die Sie vor zwei Jahren schon eingenommen haben. Da habe ich ein Deutschlandfunk-Interview mit Ihnen gehört, wo Sie gesagt haben, wenn die ganze Liga wächst, dann ist das auch für den SC Sand keine Bedrohung. Jetzt würde ich allerdings die These aufstellen, da hat sich jetzt durchaus nochmal was getan. Denn wenn ich in die zweite Liga runterschaue, dann sehe ich da drei Vereine, die auch im Männerfußball professionell spielen. Das sind Rasenball, Sport Leipzig, der 1. FC Nürnberg und der FC Ingolstadt. Und ich sehe gleich vier Zweitvertretungen von anderen Vereinen. Frankfurt, Bayern, Hoffenheim und Wolfsburg haben ihre zweiten Mannschaften in der 2. Liga. Aktuell sieht es im Aufstiegsrennen so aus, als ob mit Meppen und Duisburg jetzt nochmal andere Arten von Vereinen aufsteigen. Aber haben Sie da nicht die Sorge, dass selbst in der 2. Liga irgendwann für einen so eigenständigen Verein wie den SCS kein Platz mehr ist?
Weil wir dann bei dem Punkt wieder sind, wie wir der SC Sand wahrgenommen. Das ist natürlich eine Aufgabe von uns, das immer richtig zu stellen. Das ist fast schon gebetsmühlenartig. Ich lade immer alle ein, ob das Spielerinnen, Berater, Fans, Medien, wie auch immer, dass sie doch bitte kommen, sich das anschauen, sich vor allem auch mit uns unterhalten, sich auch mal den Trainingsbetrieb anschauen sollen und die Möglichkeiten, die wir haben. Also, wie gesagt, wir haben für die Trainingsarbeit GPS-Geräte, wir sind technisch auf dem besten Stand. Das haben dann in der zweiten Liga auch nicht so viele andere Mannschaften, selbst die Zweitvertretung von Bundesliga-Vereinen nicht, wobei da manchmal sollte es nicht am Geld scheitern bei solchen, ich sage fast schon Kleinigkeiten. Aber natürlich, wenn da auch ernsthaft an den zweiten Mannschaften und da der Kader entsprechend aufgestellt wird und wenn es dann Mannschaften gibt wie Leipzig und jetzt Duisburg-Meppen, die oben dabei sind und auch noch andere nachwachsen, ich sage ja Dortmund, vielleicht auch Stuttgart, Schalke, die sind da ja auch so ein bisschen mit dran. Ich finde es in Summe natürlich richtig gut. Und das habe ich vor zwei Jahren schon gesagt, wenn die Tendenz in die Richtung geht, der Frauenfußball an sich wächst, da sind wir ja auch wieder beim Thema Sichtbarkeit, Zuschauervermarktung an sich, dann wird es auch so kommen, dass in der zweiten Liga entsprechende Vereine drin sind, die das dann genauso professionell betreiben. Und dann hätte ich persönlich überhaupt nichts dagegen, wenn wir dann in so einer zweiten Liga spielen, wo die Breite dann einfach auch gegeben ist und wir eben nicht so ein bisschen die Situation haben, wie wir es jetzt in den letzten Jahren hatten, wo einfach dann die zweite Liga, die Diskrepanz von zweiter zu erster Liga einfach viel zu groß ist. Das war ja jetzt die letzten Jahre auch immer so der erste Absteiger, war dann im nächsten Jahr der erste Aufsteiger. Ich würde es mir vielleicht sogar für die kommende Saison wünschen. Aber an sich, wie gesagt, bin ich da einfach fähig davon, wenn die Breite wächst und wenn der Frauenfußball an sich da einfach Schritte nach vorne geht, dann ist es vielleicht auch mal an der Zeit, dass der SC Sand dann nur noch Zweite Liga spielt. Oder die Ligen müssen auch in meinen Augen aufgestockt werden mit zwölf Mannschaften in der ersten Liga. Das ist ja auch für die Außendarstellung, das ist für viele Fußballfans keine richtige Liga. Es ist jetzt noch nicht so weit, aber vielleicht, wenn es dann eben mehr Mannschaften gibt, die diese Möglichkeiten haben, dass man das einfach in die Richtung schiebt. Dann wird es mit Sicherheit auch Möglichkeiten weiterhin für den SC Sand geben.
Aber es könnte ja auch die Situation eintreten, dass wir vielleicht in fünf Jahren nochmal sprechen und dann spielen in der zweiten Liga vielleicht schon acht Zweitvertretungen von Erstligateams. Das sind dann alles solche Teams, die innerhalb ihrer Region um Aufmerksamkeit mit dem Männerfußball konkurrieren. Und wir sehen ja auch so Beispiele wie Wolfsburg und Bayern, die tun zwar viel, auch in dieser Saison dafür, sich irgendwie aus dem Schatten der Männer zu lösen, aber sie stehen sogar von den Anstoßzeiten her manchmal in direkter Konkurrenz zu denen. Ist das nicht auch aus ihrer Sicht eine Dystopie, weil ein Verein wie der SCS, der ja quasi seiner eigenen Struktur eine ganz andere Bedeutung haben muss innerhalb der Region, in der er arbeitet, für die wird ja der Platz immer kleiner. Und selbst wenn sich Sand, die ja eben, Sie haben es ja vorhin schon angesprochen, seit acht Jahren Erstligist, also da muss man jetzt nicht unbedingt Angst haben, dass da sportlich alles auseinanderfällt. Aber dann gibt es ja andere Vereine, über die wir jetzt gerade nicht gesprochen haben, die dann verdrängt werden aus dieser zweiten Liga.
Oder generell den, ja, man muss ja auch wieder nur ein bisschen zu den Herren schauen. Also wenn es in die Richtung geht, von unten, dann andere Vereine auch noch hochkommen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, wir bauen dem Männerfußball nach nur in kleiner. Das ist so, glaube ich, meine Ausgangsthese. Und dann ist die erste Frauenbundesliga irgendwann eben mit den Zweitvertretungen von Männervereinen plus noch drei, vier weitere aufgebaut. Und die zweite Liga ist dann die zweite Runde von denen. Und da können ja dann gar nicht viele Zuschauer kommen. Also ist ja klar, warum soll ich zur zweiten Mannschaft der FC Bayern Frauen gehen, ohne jetzt deren Leistung kleinreden zu wollen?
Ja, das Thema hatten wir auch. Wie sprechen Sie an Männerfußball, was die Zweitvertretung dann teilweise angeht? Ähnlich ist dann immer die Frage, wie kann man das als DFB vielleicht auch steuern? Oder wie kann der Frauenfußball einerseits machen, diese Vereine alle gute Arbeit? Gerade was den Jugendbereich angeht, wenn sie die Mädels vom U17-Bereich dann auch weiter fördern, die dann auch einfach vom Standort dort bleiben können, wo sie vielleicht auch in dem Bereich ihren Schulabschluss gemacht haben, studienbedingt auch viel besser aufgehoben sind und gute Möglichkeiten haben. Andererseits, so wie Sie es auch sagen, wenn es dann in der zweiten Liga so weit führt, dass kleinere Vereine, die auch nicht diese wirtschaftlichen Möglichkeiten haben, sich so zu positionieren. Wenn FC Bayern und Wolfsburg, wenn die es ernst machen, dann haben die in 50 Spielerinnen ein Kader und haben dann einfach zwei oder drei Top-Bundesliga-Mannschaften stellen, dann bleiben natürlich andere auf der Strecke. Dann ist immer das Thema der Identität und auch dieser Tradition, die es im Frauenfußball in vielen Bereichen gibt, da sind ja auch schon viele Mannschaften auf der Strecke geblieben. Da gab es auch mal ganz andere, wie Klinges Eckach, Brauweiler etc., die es nicht mehr gibt oder mittlerweile in anderer Form. Schwierig jetzt auch für mich, da eine passende Meinung zu haben und wie sich das entwickelt. Ich finde ja, beide Seiten aktuell haben ihre Berechtigung. Ich finde, wie gesagt, oft sind die Möglichkeiten einfach auch bei den Bundesliga-Vereinen auch gut, um die Spielerinnen zu entwickeln und auch in jungen Jahren dahin zu bringen, ohne dann auch einen Standortwechsel zu haben. Wir haben ja auch schon profitiert als SC Sand von solchen Vereinen, wo wir dann einfach Spielerinnen bekommen haben, die ausgebildet wurden in der zweiten Mannschaft, die es dann im ersten Step nicht Wolfsburg, Bayern etc. gleich in den Kader schaffen, sondern im Zwischenstep SC Sand gemacht haben, bei uns dann ein, zwei Jahre spielen, sich an die Bundesliga gewöhnen, dann Leistungsträgerinnen werden und dann eben zur Erstvertretung kommen. Das hat den SC Sand auch ein paar Jahre ausgezeichnet, dass wir genau diese Wege gehen konnten. Das wird uns aktuell so ein bisschen erschwert, weil wir eben genauso als Ausbildungsverein, und uns wird so ein bisschen die Infrastruktur ja auch immer abgesprochen und die Möglichkeit, die Mädels zu entwickeln. Das sehe ich eben nicht so, aber da müssen dann natürlich auch andere Vereine mitentscheiden. Sind sie da bereit, Spielerinnen auszuleihen zum SC Sand, oder auch die Berater, sind die da bereit, ihre Talente auch nach Sand zu schicken für ein, zwei, drei Jahre, um dann eben diesen nächsten Step zu gehen. Wir haben es jetzt erst wieder bewiesen mit der Noemi Gentile, die nach Potsdam wechselt. Die haben wir aber aus Freiburg geholt, weil sie dort überhaupt nicht mehr zur Disposition stand. Die wurde quasi in die Regionalliga abgeschoben. Wir waren dann quasi in Aufhangbecken. Es war eher nicht so, dass man sagen konnte, wir von Freiburgeseite, wir bilden die aus und schieben die vielleicht auch wieder zurück. Sondern da war es einfach so. Aber man hat dann auch bei der Noé oder auch bei der Chiara los, die wir aus der Brücken geholt haben, aus der zweiten Liga. Da haben wir wieder zwei ganz tolle Beispiele, dass es über den SC Sand dann auch zum nächsten Step geht. Und dass es ganz wichtig ist, vor allem auch Spielzeiten und Spielankeile zu bekommen, auch eine wichtige Rolle zu spielen, um sich zu entwickeln. Und da ist so das Thema, kriegt man das dann in der zweiten Liga, wo das Niveau nicht ganz so ist. Bei uns hat man das ja auch in letzter Zeit eben noch auf Top-Niveau oder gegen die Top-Gegner bekommen. Da machen die Mädels dann einfach diesen Schritt eher als in einer Zweitvertretung.
Abschließende Frage, weil wir auch schon ein bisschen über der Zeit sind. Wenn Sie jetzt fünf Jahre in die Zukunft blicken, glauben Sie, dass sich grundsätzlich was an der Aufstellung der Ligen verändert haben wird? Also Größe haben Sie jetzt schon angesprochen, aber auch, was zum Beispiel den Unterschied zwischen den Zweitvertretungen und eben den reinen Frauenfußballverein angeht. Wie oft führen Sie solche Gespräche, wie wir es jetzt geführt haben, auch innerhalb der Liga und mit dem DFB?
Es gibt immer so Manager-Tagungen, wobei ich noch einen geregelten Job habe. Ich bin da nicht immer dabei. Da haben wir die Jessica Prelle bei uns im Verein, die da teilweise in diesen Gesprächen auch näher dabei ist. Wir tauschen uns natürlich dann aus, was wurde besprochen. Ich gehe natürlich davon aus, dass, wenn man fünf Jahre nach vorne blickt, dass wir einfach eine Mannschaftsaufstockung brauchen in der ersten Liga, um diese Ligenstruktur. Meine Meinung ist, mit zwölf Mannschaften ist eine Liga nicht gut aufgestellt. Ich würde mir mindestens zwei Mannschaften mehr wünschen, dass man diesen Ligakarakter, wie man ihn aus dem Fußball kennt, eher bekommt. Ich sage nochmal, mehr in die Zukunft gesprochen sollten es vielleicht sogar 16 Mannschaften sein, um einfach in diesen Bereich zu kommen. Generell, wenn man nach vorne blickt, klar, ich wünsche mir generell diese Entwicklung, die in meinen Augen zwar sehr langsam in Deutschland vorangeht, aber sie geht voran. Andere Länder machen uns das gerade ein bisschen vor, in Spanien und in England. Aber jetzt haben wir eine EM vor der Tür. Da hoffen wir natürlich auch, dass wir als deutsche Nationalmannschaft gut abschneiden. Ich glaube, das kann dann auch nochmal einen Push geben für eine Folgesaison und für die Wahrnehmung. Und dann muss man natürlich sehen, gibt es andere Vereine, die jetzt nochmal nachziehen können. Das sind vielleicht auch Vereine wie wir als SC Sand oder, wenn ich Beispiele nehme, Andernach in der zweiten Liga. Was passiert dort? Gibt es dort Möglichkeiten der Vermarktung? Gibt es dort Firmen, die einfach noch eher mit reingehen, unterstützen? Wie sind die Entwicklungen? Wir müssen natürlich kreativ sein. Wir müssen an unserer Öffentlichkeitsarbeit weiterarbeiten, damit wir auch entsprechend wahrgenommen werden. Dass es gerade bei uns in der Region dann auch wahrgenommen wird. Oder auch bundesweit wahrgenommen wird. Hey, hier wird Profifußball gespielt. Hier ist eine Mannschaft von zwölf, die in der Bundesliga spielt. Und das kann ja für mich als Firma, egal wo die sitzt, bei einem bundesweiten Produkt immer attraktiv sein. Und da muss man natürlich sehen, gibt es vielleicht da den einen oder anderen Ansatz, wo wir auch dadurch wachsen können. Im Endeffekt geht es immer darum, Gelder zu generieren, um wachsen zu können und gute Arbeit zu leisten. Da sehe ich dann eigentlich schon Möglichkeiten. Aber man muss die Tür aufstoßen, man muss gute Arbeit leisten. Man muss vor allem dabei bleiben. Wenn wir jetzt runtergehen, müssen wir gucken, dass wir auch wieder zurückkommen. Dass wir uns entsprechend aufstellen, weil nur dann ist man sichtbar. Und es ist vielleicht auch gewährleistet, dass man diese Möglichkeiten bekommt.
Herr Reiß, ich danke Ihnen sehr für das Gespräch. Ich wünsche viel Erfolg und gute Narven für den letzten Spieltag in Hoffenheim. Danke Ihnen für Ihre Zeit. Das war das, was Sascha Reiß zur aktuellen Situation in der Liga und auch der möglichen Zukunft zu sagen hatte. Herzlichen Dank nochmal für das Gespräch. Und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwilligen Zahlungen. Wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Und generell solltet ihr mal auf rasenfunk.de gehen, denn wir haben ein komplett neues Design. Die Seite, sie sieht anders aus. Schaut sie euch an, hört uns, bleibt uns treu. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Und dann hören wir uns bald hier wieder in Rasenfunk Kurzpass, sehr wahrscheinlich 204 dann. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund, macht's gut.